sean carroll who is a proponent of the
many worlds says to you carlo you're
trying to hold you say that the many
worlds is distasteful because look the
cost yeah but you're calling it a cost
because you're trying to hold on to
something else so what if sean says that
to you
um
i i am in a discussion with with sean on
one another thing he
not only uh
take the many world
interpretations seriously he likes it
but he likes a particularly radical
version
of the um
of the
if
latino
not radical enough already right
he yeah he he called it the mag dog he
called it the mad dog
uh
many world interpretation the mad dog
in which there is only hilbert space and
state and hamiltonian nothing else so
you want to extract everything from
from that
uh i'm i'm
i i'm debating that i i think it's not
going to work in general activity for
this and that reason i mean he has he
has an answer which is yeah you know
you have this terminal time i can use
your term of time to make it answer so
he's trying to use my own ideas against
myself
um
uh what would he say
to me well i think that there is a he
belongs to a
um
a group of physicists that are very much
in love with many world because they
find it very simple and and
straightforward there's just this wave
function
and out of this wave function we can
extract
um
we can extract the rest so um
uh i i never heard
him
um
telling me what he thinking the
relational interpretation
is wrong because when we when we have
talked with um we talked about his ideas
uh
especially his this mad dog version of
of evelette and i i sort of uh tried to
point out what what are the the the
technical limitations of this
of this idea
there is some people who learned quantum
mechanics
starting from schrodinger
and can only think about quantum
mechanics in terms of the wave function
the
quantum mechanic was not born with
schrodinger was born with heisenberg and
max borgnon
and uh
um the the the gottingen
people in matrix mechanics before
schrodinger paulie dirac
uh and it can be thought without any
wave function without any uh
any state
and i think that uh by introducing the
uh the wave function
should confuse things made calculation
easier but confused the ontology the
picture so everybody started thinking
about this wave and
got confused
um
i think that uh
sean is definitely not making the
mistake of uh
holding on to classical intuition
to the opposite he he takes the
the schrodinger way function very
seriously tried to build everything
from that so he's blaming me probably uh
what
i am blaming
wolfram and lee
uh namely that i want to stay attached
to classical
to variables having values described in
the world in terms of facts
um
that's probably what he
he wanted to
he would like to blame me
my answer is that
i think it doesn't work to think that
the world is just the way function is
the way he would like to he would like
to say the way function nothing else
there's this vector in hilbert space and
nothing else
and i think that uh
vector number spaces don't give me pens
don't give me
books don't give me the concrete
description of the world to
to to have a quantum theory you need
much more
many ingredients
uh
so it's not clean the pure wave function
picture of the world
um you need the operators you need again
values you need again vectors you need
this structure
and this structure he hopes to just take
it out from the hamiltonian
but once again i have not
seen it happening uh
yet so i think that
um
this way of thinking about quantum
mechanics is not going to be
fruitful we need the algebra observance
quantum mechanics about non-communicable
non-computer variables the core of
quantum mechanics is p q minus q p equal
i h bar
this is the core
of of quantum mechanics variables don't
commute like an unknown would insist
upon it's a discovery that the variables
we use to describe the world
are not always defined because there are
no commuting so they cannot be both
defined at the same time that's core
not the wave function
how is he throwing that out by trying to
put so much emphasis on the wave
function how is he throwing out those
non-commuting operators oh that's the
mag
the mother dog interpretation there are
no
no
no
operators at the fundamental level
there's only the wave function and then
he says there's hamiltonian
and the amazonian has some structure
in it and from the structure of the
hamiltonian
one can
okay derive from the structure of the
comet the composition of hilbert spaces
in
subsystems
and is some system from the subsystem i
can extract something which correspond
to the algebra observables so it's a
very indirect way of trying to
extract it from the dynamics it's a
dynamics that
should give us the variables
it's a long way to go
is there a reason that he's starting
he's saying that there let's imagine the
wave function of the universe seen
quantum field theory and i'm not saying
anything you don't know it
it's like operator value it's not that
people say it's field but it's like a
strange field it's an operator valued
field because it's not exactly what yeah
the mystics say it's like all like water
and waves well it's like an operator
wave if you want to call that so why is
he not using why is he going why is he
going to qm and our q of t
in other words
like the wave function of h no no no he
he has in mind uh quantum field theory
he has my qft but but but this
particular structure that defined qft
he would like
to say that he's only written in the
hamiltonian
uh so he would not he would say that you
know for the mentality of the world is
not
qft is it's a very rich structure as you
say there are these quantum fields which
are actually operated this is local
quantum operators um it's a field of
operators
uh which commute don't commute have this
all this problem so you have to give all
this machinery to make it work
and this machinery the operators the
fields are absorbable so what we
interact describe how we interact with
the field right
uh he want to discard all that
he want to say there's only
a big guild of space a hub space is just
free or grey thing we don't require
anything else
okay
and it's just how the
what gives the motion
of of of the state in the him the space
but he will say the hamiltonian has some
structure inside it because it we can
it's eigen values have some structure
some some some way of combining them and
we secretly know
about all the machinery of quantum field
theory
uh it's it's a technical step i don't
know if i if i need to go into that
um
but but but he has in mind
quantification in fact the the property
of the hamiltonian that
he uses is the locality of the
interaction
it can be written as a
and the locality gives the region of
space
uh
so here's this
this extreme everything or extreme uh
uh
uh many world
and my objection
is you need a hamiltonian you don't have
an eternity generativity because there's
no time